who is such a tricky question to answer
hi my name is Salani and i have been a
science teacher for about five years my
name is Jenny and I have been teaching
in a preschool for about 10 years now hi
I'm Dan I was an adjunct professor in
art and film and today I'm going to be
answering some commonly googled
questions about teaching education
schools can teachers smoke weed well I
feel like that's one of those questions
that you don't want to answer I mean I
guess if nobody knows what you're doing
you just do what you got to do from my
perspective
teaching college yes you can we did not
have drug testing of that nature I don't
really know the law when it comes to
public school teachers I don't know off
the top of my head my school's policy on
it but I would just guess that they
would prefer that you not come to work
high they would probably prefer it if
you were sober in the classroom and I
would assume that most schools would
have that policy so I would hope that
most teachers would follow that as well
I think that they're not legally
supposed to smoke weed but I think that
they should be allowed to matter of fact
I think they should add that into their
page just go on and throw in weed in the
pay so that we could be better teachers
there have been plenty of situations
where I've needed weed not only wanted
but needed weed when I've been cussed
out by a parent because their child is
bad like I've substituted a couple times
and when there's really really rowdy
kids I had a kid WWE like slam somebody
on a table definitely needed the weed
why are teachers underpaid
[Laughter]
that's such a tricky question to answer
question when somebody finds the answer
please tell me because schools don't
have the money to give teachers what
they deserve
schools are underfunded the state gives
money to a school they are essentially
investing in the future of their city
and of the world really you're not gonna
see return on that investment for many
many many years but it is essentially
the way that capitalism looks at you why
our schools overcrowded there are a lot
of people in the world and again it
comes back to funding and the ability to
build new academic institutions is not
there without money if it's a public
school it's just probably the most
available school that is out there so
public schools are crowded because
they're free you just want to give all
of your attention to as many kids as you
can and the more kids you have the
harder it is to focus that attention on
the individual students will school ever
end well that's kind of up to you it
feels like never feels like no matter
what you're always going to school
you're always learning school will never
end you guys you're gonna be learning
forever and we have a baby if you get
married you're gonna learn so no the
school doesn't end you think it does and
then it gets worse it doesn't feel like
it'll ever end when you're a teacher but
it does end eventually it legally ends
when you graduate high school there are
of course exceptions to that you don't
have to stay if you don't want to stay
but I think you should because cliches
it may be you are the future of this
country
we are struggling to get through these
final days of school just keep going
just know that you can do it you're
amazing
you got this because honestly it's worth
it in the end I promise will teachers be
replaced by AI I hope not because then I
will lose my job
oh I've taught online classes before so
that's a slippery slope for sure you
know what I really wouldn't doubt the
teachers are never gonna be replaced
that would be sad because that's where I
got the most
outside of the home was with the teacher
like talking to a person so that'd be so
weird and sad will they probably should
they hell no I don't think so because I
think you need that warmth of a real
person I could definitely foresee a
future in which teachers are replaced by
a I don't think it's a healthy future to
imagine but it's certainly a realistic
one an AI can't replicate feelings if a
child has you know had an accident or
hurt themselves I don't think an AI is
gonna walk up to the big child and say
oh it's gonna be okay they're gonna be
like get back to your seats you guys got
some interesting questions on Google but
now I want to know what other questions
are out there if you have questions for
teachers you should just ask teachers
Google can give you a lot of
misinformation and no one teacher is the
same I know every teacher is kind of
lumped into teachers think like this or
teachers are like that but we are all
unique individuals just like you are all
unique individuals but I think wanting
to be educated wanting to learn is
amazing and always keep seeking that I
need smarter people in the world
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]